hello everyone and welcome to a
conclusion video of the world blitz
championship 2021 uh we're going to show
two to get two games in this video first
we're going to show maxim garcia lagrave
versus magnus carlsen and then we're
going to show another one uh but we'll
get to that and it was very interesting
because uh during the final round six
people were tied for first place uh and
the magnus was half a point behind them
uh other games uh that were fighting for
first place were some of them were very
interesting but uh for example uh dubo
also had a shot
of reaching the top but uh he uh
agreed to to a draw against the
nishigiri only after six moves were
played i don't know why maybe it's the
the money prize because as i understand
that there are like 40 money prizes uh
throughout the event uh so maybe he was
going for one of those as maybe it was
not possible for him to win first place
uh but it's hard to say now all in all i
was not very happy to see that
then duda uh who is uh playing a a great
tournament uh won a game against ladies
lavartemive uh which propelled him uh
all the way to the top alireza defeated
levon uh which also uh propelled him to
the top but we're gonna discuss the
standings a little bit later but this is
the game that we have to see in order to
fully understand the the ending so maxim
with the white pieces opens with e4 we
have e5 by magnus knight f3 knight to c6
and now bishop to b5 going for the real
lopez with a6 morpheus defense bishop to
a4 and now knight to f6 we have castles
and bishop to e7 so a nice uh close rule
lopez uh we have rook to e1 and
b5 now chasing away the bishop bishop to
b3 and now magnus castles and here the
question uh always must be asked the is
white ready to challenge black to a
martial attack and if uh maxine play c3
here no doubt magnus will go for the
martial attack but of course he doesn't
he plays the anti-martial variation with
a4 bishop to b7 and now d3 we have d6 so
this is all very very standard stuff
just putting pieces to their rightful
squares rook to e8 preparing bishop to
f8 knight to f1 and now h6 we have c3
and bishop to f8 so this has been seen
many many times on in top level chess
knight to the e3 and knight to e7 now
magnus renewing the knight all the way
to g6
we have h3 and knight the g6 now we have
knight to the h2 and now there is a game
where knight to f4 was played but here
magnus strikes in the center with the d5
and it is now as a move 15 that we have
a completely new game
uh so what do you do here well it's a
three minute blitz game okay three plus
two but still a three minute blitz game
and you don't have time to you know
discover new ground really so you
capture the pawn e captures on d5 knight
captures on d5 and now queen f3 a very
nice move by maxine uh the knight can't
move well just about anywhere because oh
well you are
going to lose that f7 pawn so knight to
h4 magnus attacks the queen on f3 and
the now queen to e4 queen to g4 is a
safer idea but maxine puts his queen on
a very
uh awkward e4 square and magnus
immediately goes after
the knight on e3 knight captures on e3
grabs a piece and is threatening to pick
up that g2 pawn
maxim has to go into it because well
that's why he played queen e4 but a
queen captures on b7 knight captures on
b2 although you could also throw in a
nice rook to b8 but okay knight captures
in g2 uh we have rook to e4 now
preparing rook to g4 to pick up the
knight and then the other knight
and now queen captures on d3 by magnus
now preparing queen captures an h3 and
this is a complete mess of a position uh
rook the g4 now threatening to capture
the knight and now queen captures an
h3 by magnus b captures on a4 is always
in the position although it looks like
you're just grabbing a pawn you're
really not you're asking white what do
you do because i'm threatening rook b8
and you're gonna lose that bishop on b3
and it's not just a piece it's an
incredible attacker here uh you know
completely slicing the board in half but
okay magnus played queen captures on h3
and now uh he overlooked a beautiful
move that maxim also overlooked i have
to remind everyone this is a
three-minute blitz game uh here maxine
played rook to g3 he attacked the queen
but there is one move you have to play
before that and that's queen to d5 and
now how do you defend f7 it's just not
possible uh if you defend it with rook
to e7 or rook to
e6 then you lose the the rook on a8 uh
obviously you can't play that and the
problem is if king h7 uh queen captures
an f7 and it's game over there's no
defense queen to g7 will be checkmate
the rook covers the g6 square and you
can't really move the bishop because
then queen captures and g7 is checkmate
so of course maxine isn't uh really
banking on magnus missing something like
this so he doesn't look for it so rook
the g3
we have queen back to f5 now the pawn is
nicely defended so queen d5 no longer
serves any purpose and now rook captures
on g2 i think maxine was just focused
on grabbing that knight on g2 and he
didn't want to you know waste any time
on looking for other things
knight captures on g2 although uh b
captures on a4 is always uh possible but
okay
knight captures we have queen captures
on g2 and now rook a to d8
so now uh magnus has a rook for a light
square bishop and the knight and if he
can put those
rooks to good use it's going to be great
if not then well maxine will have a lot
to fight with and you can play rook d1
of course the bishop covers that so you
have to find some other way uh uh
to to attack the black king you're kind
of hoping to get this rook to d6 the g6
in but it's not going to be easy we have
knights to g4 and now king to h8 already
there's a threat of knight captures an
h6 check and you're gonna lose the queen
so king h8 magnus has to play this now a
captures on b five a captures and the
knight the e3 now attacks the queen
queen to h5 and now knight to f1 so you
have this knight the g3 move to
defend
any of those rook moves uh and magnus uh
advances the e for pawn we have knight
to g3 attacking the queen putting
pressure on the pawn queen to g6 and now
bishop to e3 so maxine putting his
pieces on optimal squares as you can see
and bishop to d6 a very nicely placed
bishop we have knight to e2 now offering
a queen trade and magnus declines the
queen trade we have queen to h5 but
again it's uh it's impossible to bring
the rook into the attack because the
bishops cover e6 and g5 and you can play
rook to e6 to go g6 and you can play
rook to e5 to go g5 as the bishops are
just doing a wonderful job here so
knight back to g3 attacks the queen and
here if magnus doesn't want to repeat he
has to do something so we have bishop
captures on g3 f captures on g3 and now
rook to d3 at least magnus gets to
activate his rooks this way
uh queen to f2 and now we have f5 magnus
starts the attack uh bishop to c2 chases
away the rook rook to d6 and now king to
g2 preparing rook to h1 to get the queen
away from such a lovely square
we have rook e to d8 doubling up on the
d file and then now rook to h1 we have
queen to g6 and now bishop to f4 those
bishops are just
beautiful
attacking while also defending not
allowing rook to d2
uh so rook d5 and now queen to e2
we have c5 by magnus as he knows that
maxine wants to play b3 and c4 so he's
preparing c4 himself b3 and now c4
our good friend uh the the engine says
queen to c6 can be very very strong
because well the the king is on g2 uh
but okay uh c4 we have b captures on c
for b captures and now rook to f1 uh
you want to maybe play rook to f2 so you
don't have to worry about this bishop
always guarding the d2 square it's just
very very safe
and here magnus played rook a queen to
f6 and it's a really weird move to play
with queen the c6 magnus still keeps the
edge aligns the queen with the king on
this diagonal and is ready to
do some damage but here he played queen
to f6 which is very odd he's attacking
the c3 pawn but he's blundering the c4
pawn and as it turns out it's a very
important pawn so maxine captures it we
have queen to b6 and now comes bishop to
b3
so what do you do here uh here rook to
c5 by magnus again magnus had the
opportunity of playing e3 is just a
beautiful move where white is uh uh out
of good options really uh best for white
is just to give up the queen for two
rooks and that's it try and try and play
this game because it is just not not a
good position with the d2 is coming and
well this e3 move is just beautiful it's
um
it's uh well it's uh it's a shame for
black that it didn't happen uh so rook
to c5 magnus goes after the queen but
now queen to f7 and now magnus is
already in big trouble here magnus
played rook captures on c3 he can't
really afford to go after this pawn he
has to play queen to f6 but okay rook
captures on c3 was played and now he
misses something incredible feel free to
pause the video and win the game for
maxine while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that mate
is inevitable and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show maxime just
played bishop to e5 and now there is
really nothing uh that magnus can do
here uh let me just check uh i'm not
sure at what position exactly did magnus
resign in
but i don't want to you know misinform
you guys so let me just check this real
quickly
uh
okay yeah
so after this bishop to e5 move magnus
played rook to d2 check uh even though
uh there's really no better move uh even
if you try something like rook captures
on g3 because you can't defend against
mate and uh well even rook the g8 is
impossible uh to guard this g7 pawn
because we just captured queen captures
with checkmate because our bishop is
still on b3 so here you might go for
something like this simply to get the
bishop away from this diagonal and then
trade queens but you are down too much
material for example captures captures
and uh captures uh queen captures on f7
and rook cap story rook captures uh
you're down two bishops of course it's
completely winning so instead magnus
played rook to d to check maxine played
king to h1 and it was in this position
animal 47 that magnus cross and resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here it's impossible to defend
against checkmate and there is simply no
move you can make here to even make it a
little bit interesting is just uh
completely lost for for him
so uh maxim is propelled uh all the way
to the top with 15 points and that means
that uh maxima sherlock young
are tied for first place but as the
rules state only two players will play
uh the the the playoffs and that means
that the players with the with the best
additional criteria uh will face each
other and alireza dropped out so alireza
will not be playing and now we will see
the game that won first place and that
is of course maxine vashiolagrav versus
young shisht of duda here let's just
load the dudes game
and uh this is the third blizz game so
the rules of the of the tie breaks are
uh we play blitz games uh three plus two
uh until someone wins of course the
first we play uh
one game and game two and only then if
it's a draw then we play whoever wins
first if we can play until tomorrow
until someone wins those are the rules
uh so
it's not a new rule i've i've been told
that it has been used before by fides so
you know
as the games are very very short it's
possible to
uh
en enforce them and endure them uh but
okay let's uh check it out third game
first two games ended in a draw max
theme opens with e4 and we're gonna have
another very nice rue lopez a knight of
three knight to c6 bishop to b5 sam is
in the game against magnus a6 amorphy's
defense bishop a4 knight f6 bishop uh
sorry castles bishop to e7 and now not
going for rook to e1 like he did against
magnus here he goes for d3 we have b5
bishop to b3 d6 a3 and castle so this is
all very well known stuff knight to c3
and now knight to b8 another standard
maneuver uh you are preparing to strike
in the against the center with c5 and
you're going to shift this knight over
to some now to some better squares uh so
here we have bishop to d2 and now knight
b to d7 we have a4 and duda grabs more
space with b4 chases away the knight
knight d5 and now a5 and here there is a
game where bishop to e3 was played but
uh here maxine plays c3 and it is now as
of move 13 that we have a completely new
game
uh so do the capture said we have bishop
captures in c3
and now knight to c5 going after the
bishop here but this is how maxine saves
it knight captures on f6 bishop captures
and bishop to d5 attacks the rook we
have rook to a7 and now queen to c2 uh
developing the queen still defending our
d3 pawn
we have bishop the g4 now threatening to
ruin black's king side a little bit but
maxine finds d4 an incredibly strong
move because if you go after the knight
now we simply capture on c5 and your
bishop is now hanging so you'd have to
move the bishop and then we can play
some like b4 and the fake captures
bishop captures uh white's position is
excellent you can't capture otherwise
bishop captures attack both attacks both
of the rooks and you already have a past
a pawn that you're ready to push so
white would enjoy this position very
much so instead e captures on d4 was
played knight captures on d4 and bishop
back to d7 keeping an eye on that's a
knight to the c6 move so knight to b5
attacking the rook and now bishop
captures on b5 with eight captures and
now bishop captures on c3 queen captures
on c3 and now a4 so this is uh how do
that will defend his spawn
but
that also means that the knight and rook
are somewhat stuck here defending this
pawn for for
uh well for the perceivable uh future so
here we have queen to a queen to e3 you
could also try e5 because black can
never capture but uh it doesn't really
force anything so maxine uh holds off
with the e5 push we have queen to e3
aligning the queen with the rook on a7
so uh do the defense that we have queen
to b8 and now bishop to c6 defending the
v5 pawn
and it's not much but maxine has a very
firm grip on the position the queen and
rook here are are completely useless on
the queen side and the bishop also
covers the e8 square so rook to e8 is
not happening it's hard to find uh
good pieces uh good squares for judah's
pieces so here queen to b6
but now rook 8 to d1
we have rooked the b8 and now we have e5
finally maxim opens up the position and
the problem with capturing the pawn is
that uh duda will keep a passive
position for for pretty much the rest of
the game if you capture this queen
captures what do you play
you can't really do all that much rook
covers the eight bishop covers e8 the
queen rook nothing can get into the game
and for example if knight to e6 we're
gonna play rook to d7 and it's just very
very bad for black so instead uh duda
tries to give up a pawn to you know get
it get something out of the position he
plays knight to e6 gives up the d6 pawn
and now maxine says all right i will
trade queens and go for the same game so
queen captures rook captures we have
pawn capture spawn captures and rook
captures on d6 and now a3 we have to
exchange this pawn to activate our rook
so b captures with rook captures on a3
and now g3 creating some breeding room
for the king and now we will activate
our rook and uh well it's pretty much an
equal position except for maxime's past
pawn on b5 so here we have g6 dude also
create some breeding room for the king
rook to d7 now it's you also have to be
careful because the f7 pawn is also
somewhat weak so rook to b8 and now we
have rook to b1 preparing to push our
pawn and you can't just block it if you
block it we're going to play rook b7 and
still we're going to push our pawn so uh
sorry so maxine goes to rook to c3 dude
that goes rook to c3 and now rook to a1
preparing the other rook lift
and then it's going to be very difficult
to defend the seventh rank so knight to
d8 we are now ready to defend uh bishop
to d5 now putting more pressure on f7
and here uh it's not easy to defend
there's really no good way to stop rook
to a7 so maybe uh
rook c the c8 gives some counter play
for for black but not a lot uh duda
played king to f8 but this just makes it
uh much much easier for maxine he goes
rook a to a7
rook to d3 now prevents bishop captures
because we will first capture the rook
uh but now uh king the g2 maxime starts
bringing the king into the game king g7
we have bishop the c for now attacking
the rook and also offering a rook trade
so rook captures the rook captures and
now king f6 we have b6 uh pushing the
pass pawn with a tactic because if rook
captures rook captures knight so knight
to a6 and now b7 and this is now a very
nicely advanced pass pawn
g5 by duda now bishop captures an e6
maxine is confident that he will win
this rook and pawn end game uh you can't
capture with the pawn because then we
capture the h7 pawn so king captures on
e6 and now rook c7 and you can't go
after the rook
because we will capture on f7
uh so uh h5 is played we have king to f3
that's not a king king to f3 maxim
starts bringing his king into the game
and now f5 and of course h4 uh to to
players like maximum maximum duda this
this is a very well known end game and
of course they both know how to win it
so g captures on h4 uh there's really
nothing to be done here so this wasn't
played if king d6 we just go after the
the king side pawns and the you are lost
so instead after h4 king the d6 was
played going after the rook but not rook
to h7 uh we have a trait here captures
captures king to e5 but now king e3 uh
the opposition is there there's nothing
for you to do uh rook the d8 was played
uh and well here dude uh maxine just
captured the h5 pawn and he was in this
position on mu 49 that young shisht of
duda resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here he's down
two pawns and then of course is uh
easily winning uh you know uh
on on many different uh
uh ways
uh so yeah that's basically how maxine
became the world blitz champion 2021 so
he had a
brutal round uh a final round against
magnus carlsen he defeated magnus and
then he went into tie breaks against
duda and then only in the third game
of the blitz uh did he emerge victorious
and a lot of people were like okay this
isn't fair because dude that doesn't get
to have the white pieces in the fourth
game uh but uh tie breaks are never fair
and they will always favor
uh one of the players so
you know we we have to decide that the
champion somehow chess still hasn't
figured out how to do this uh
fairly improperly uh but yeah
congratulations to uh maxim on winning
first place duda win second place and uh
alireza furuja wins third place so so i
don't forget that these are the final
standings of the world blitz
championship 2021. so you can see mvl
first place young she used to do the
second uh alireza third the neil dubo uh
fourth so as you can see if he didn't uh
do if he didn't do his game against
geary so quickly maybe he would have won
and maybe it would have been a little
bit better but obviously not not by a
lot uh
we have arunan mamidarov artemyev cinder
of fedocev opening
magnus carlsen only in 12th place as i'm
told that this is uh carlson's worst
world and rapid world championship that
he ever played uh martin kravitz in in
13 alexander grisham mikhail
in 25th place so
uh blitz was not kind to our world
champion and the world championship
challenger we'll see what happens in the
next one but this one was very enjoyable
and you can see that um
a lot of new new players are emerging as
you can see here for example javakir
sindarov
of uzbekistan
did incredible uh work here in the blitz
section and uh well
not rebecca also did a very very
impressive work in the in the rapid
section so uh uzbekistan is really uh
you know creating some amazing chess
players uh so yeah uh those those are
the sayings hope you guys enjoyed that
and uh this short coverage of the world
blitz and rapid championship and uh yeah
like i said really hope you guys enjoyed
it for those of you who still haven't uh
feel free to send me photos or videos of
you teaching someone else how to play
chess uh if you if you guys are
interested in being in the uh just
brings people together video 2022 the
email is in the description below the
first one not the second one as a lot of
people are saying it to the wrong one so
you use the right one
uh that yeah that's it i would like to
thank george julian
la boon christian hogel drew watkins
michal calvera and john henry for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon uh continuing uh to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world so thank
you all i will see you soon and happy
new year everyone